Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P. After I posted
a horrible, horrible voicemail I received
to my Instagram, the egg man who has done
time in prison and is a Jewish man himself,
and that's relevant to the story. He called
in to weigh in on it. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave, I just went on Instagram
and listened to that voice message from the
guy in South Carolina down south saying he.
Speaker 1: Was actually West Virginia.
Speaker 2: Smacked act taste out of your mouth. It
was horribly anti-Semitic and does not like you.
Dave, I just want to tell you about those people.
I know them for real. I work with them. But best
of all, I was in prison with them. Dave You know,
I have a giant star of David Tattoo on my back. I
am obviously freaking Jewish gay. There are actual
Nazis in prison. When these people saw me with
the star David Tattoo walking around the yard or
in the TV room with no shirt on. You know what
they did to me, David? They asked me for legal
help and to get them weed shower. Shalom, brother.
Speaker 1: So the egg man, I guess, playing up
some some stereotypical tropes there. But I think
his main point is that when he faced some of these
anti-Semites in person, they weren't willing to
do the things they were willing to maybe do on
line. I guess that's the point that the egg
man is making. They're sort of interesting,
I guess. But always appreciate his insights,
that's for sure. Okay. On today's bonus show,
we will be talking about Georgia's second largest
school district, allowing non officers to carry
guns. They're doing it. It's happening. Also,
wealthy countries are talking about fourth COVID
shots. Our Macron tailored COVID shots. Much of
Africa still hasn't gotten any doses. And we're
going to talk about that. And third, this story
going viral. BMW, the vehicle manufacturer, BMW,
is offering heated seats on a monthly
subscription. The car comes equipped with them,
but you can only turn them on with a monthly
subscription. What how does that work? We will
talk about it on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by signing up at
join pacman dot. You can use the coupon
code decoding 22. We will see you then.